the professional career change really
helped because now dayto day I am paid
to be who I am when I show up at pelaton
when I have a brand partnership when I
create a business I might be developing
a new skill set or expanding an existing
one but at the core of it is who I am
and I had a period of time for eight
years where I was showing up as an
intelligent writer in the legal
profession an advocate for my clients
but there was so much of my personality
traits of my embodiment that I was
leaving at home or leaving behind closed
doors and I think now I really really
step into all of it like I don't
apologize for my drive my Swagger my
style my history my story I don't
apologize for any of it and I'm excited
to see what happens next